ARE RIGHT CAN WE DO THE ROLL
CALL PLEASE.
IRWIN HERE VOEPEL.
BOERNER HORVATH HERE BRO.
DALY.
FRAZIER GLORIA.
MATHIS.
WHERE CITY [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
SALAS. TEN OUT OF ELEVEN SIX
NINE OKAY WE ARE GOING TO HAVE --
AB.
SIX FIVE THREE A PRESENTED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOMS STAFF.
SECOND THIRD AND FOURTH.
I APOLOGIZE FOR MY TARDINESS I'M
USUALLY NOT PARTY.
PLEASE I'LL BE REALLY QUICK I'M
SORRY THE THE MEMBER CAN'T BE
HERE RIGHT NOW HE'S STUCK IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE -- UNDER THE
REALLY SHORT VERSION.
IS JUST AS IMPORTANT JUST AS
IMPORTANT SORRY SIR.
I AM.
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO PRESENT
EIGHTY SIX FIVE THREE WHICH
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE DIRECTOR
GENERAL SERVICES TO ENTER INTO A
LEASE AGREEMENT WITH THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES FOR ONE POINT
THREE ACRES THE WEST LOS ANGELES
NATIONAL GUARD.
ARMORY SITE -- LOST THE COUNTY
WALKED IN JUST UNDER LEADERSHIP
A SUPERVISOR SHE'LL KILL HAS
OVER THE LAST ONE POINT FIVE
YEARS.
BEEN WORKING WITH RELEVANT CITY
STATE AND PARTNERS TO DISCUSS
THE FEASIBILITY OF BUILDING
BRIDGE HOUSING SITE AT THE
PROPERTY.
THIS PROJECT WILL BE THE FIRST
BRIDGE HOW THE SITE FOR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AN S. P. A..
FIVE IN OVER TWENTY YEARS THE
SPECIFICS OF THE PROJECT ARE
BEING DEVELOPED WITH THE COUNTY
ARCTIC NATIONAL GUARD AND DESIGN.
SHOULD BE COMPLETED OVER THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY MARTHA GRAHAM OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER HERE WITH ME
TODAY PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MIGHT THINK REPRESENTING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS A SPONSOR OF AB SIX
FIVE THREE B. THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND HIS STAFF WHO ARE --
GREAT CONSULTANTS WHO ARE
EXPERTS ON ARE HOMELESS CRISIS
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND AB SIX
THREE FIVE THREE IS -- IS
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS -- OF BIG
HOMELESS CRISIS WE HAVE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY POINT IN TIME IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOUND THAT THERE
WERE THREE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
ANY EIGHTY INDIVIDUALS ON
SHELTERED IN THIS PARTICULAR
SERVICE AREA.
AND THIS IS SERVICE AREA FIVE
THE ONLY FIFTEEN BEDS AVAILABLE
FOR INDIVIDUALS -- SO WE ARE
LOOKING AT BUILDING -- YEAH.
BRIDGE HOUSING -- IN THE WEST LA
ARMORY JUST A PORTION OF IT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT CLOSELY THE
NATIONAL GUARD -- SO THAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE THIS AND ALSO AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL SO THAT WE CAN AND
OPT IN THE AUTHORITY.
AND WE ALSO BEEN WORKING WITH
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES IN OUR
PARTNERS -- IN THE IS US
LEGISLATURE SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IS PART.
MANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
I JUST CHECKED -- WHAT IS THE
POSITION OF A CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT?
THEY DON'T HAVE A A POSITION BUT
THEY HAVE CONTACTED -- THE
COMMITTEE -- CONSULTANT -- IN
THE ASSEMBLY ACCOUNTABILITY --
AND ADMINISTRATIVE YOU COMMITTEE
SAY THAT THEY ARE WORKING WITH
US AND THAT -- THEY DON'T HAVE
THEY DON'T TAKE A POSITION EARLY
ON IN THE PROCESS AND THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS ON THE BILL
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER.
AND THEY'VE BEEN COOPERATIVE AND
THEY DON'T SEE THIS AS AN
CONSISTENT WITH THEIR THAT WITH
THE USE OF THE THE ARMORY.
NO WE HAVE -- WORKED WITH -- OUR
PARKS AND REC DEPARTMENT SHOULD
WE NEED TO EVACUATE AND WE HAVE
WORK CALLED I'M CLOSELY IN THE
ARCHITECTURE.
OF WHERE THE LOCATION OF THIS
BRIDGE HOUSING IS SO THAT IS NOT
IN THE WAY OF DAILY OPERATIONS.
ARE THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER THANK YOU
YOU HAD MENTIONED THAT THE
DESIGN IS A COUPLE MONTHS COUPLE
MONTHS FROM BEING -- DONE WHAT
IS THE ANTICIPATED -- YOU STATE.
WE ARE LOOKING AT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY BEDS FOR MEN AND WOMEN
SINGLE MEN AND WOMEN.
WEDNESDAY CERTAIN A MOVE IN.
THE DATE -- CERTAIN WHEN IT'S
GONNA BE COMPLETED AT THIS TIME
WE IT'S IT'S ABOUT A COUPLE OF
MONTHS SO IT'S OPEN AT THIS
POINT -- AND WE ARE THAT'S THE
TIME FRAME WE'RE ANTICIPATING.
SO.
YOU'LL BE USING IT IN TWO MONTHS
NO ALL AS I'M SAYING -- WHEN ARE
YOU MOVING?
DAY FOR YOU.
BECAUSE OF YEARS YES IT'S A
COUPLE OF YEARS OKAY I WOULD
HOPE THAT YOU CAN ACCELERATE
THAT WE GET THESE PEOPLE TO
SHELTER THEY DESERVE.
YES AND IT IS -- CURRENTLY A
WARMING -- SHELTER FOR THE
WINTERS AND SO YOU'RE RIGHT I
BUT THAT'S WHY WE FOUND -- THAT
THE WOMAN CENTERS ARE NOT.
ADEQUATE WE NEED SOMETHING YEAR
ROUND FOR BRIDGE HOUSING AND
WARM I'M IN THE PROCESS WITH OUR
MEASURE H. FUNDING WE HAVE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND WITH A MEASURE HHH -- WITH
THEIR CITY OF LA PARTNER -- TO
BUILD A ROBUST -- HOUSING
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
RENTAL OF SUBSIDIZED RENTAL
UNITS AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS FOR
YOUR EFFORTS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRO THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IS WILL THIS BE
HOUSING ONLY OR WILL YOU HAVE
OTHER SERVICES LIKE MENTAL
HEALTH AND EXACTLY IT'LL BE
ALCOHOL AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
ALL THAT CORRECT WELL TO BE SO
BRIDGE HOUSING IS -- TO YOU KNOW
WHEN IT THIS IS AN AREA WHERE
IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE FOR FOLKS --
TO MOVE INTO SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
GETTING THEM OFF THE STREETS --
GETTING THEM INTO SHELTER TRENDS --
PROVIDING THAT TRANSITION
SERVICES TO GET THEM STABILIZE
CONNECTED THEM -- TO SUPPORT OF
SERVICES SO THAT YOU KNOW --
THEY THEY WONDER TRANSITIONING
WE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT WHETHER WE
NEED SUPPORT OF HOUSING -- OR
RENTAL HOUSING SO FROM THERE WE
MAKE SURE THAT THEY MAINTAIN
CONTINUITY OF CARE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD SO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS IT WAS MOVED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS AND
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER CAN I HAVE THE SECRETARY
PETE PLEASE JUST ROLL CALL --
WHEN I GREW IN AYE VOEPEL?
I FOR NO MORE THAN.
BOERNER HORVATH AYE BRO.
I DALY.
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I PETRIE-NORRIS.
NORTH AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE. TEN ZERO AND THAT
DILUTES OUT CONGRATULATIONS.
NOW WE ARE GOING -- TO KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR FOR MORE MINUTES.
THANK YOU.
I THINK
.
DALY YES DALY AYE [inaudible]
YEAH -- MOSTLY